hallo Herr Kubicki wenn man sich das so
anschaut dann könnten sie sich doch
heute hier und jetzt bei Bild live
festlegen das ist eine Ampelkoalition
nicht geben kann mit der FDP
zunächst einmal sollten Sie die Menschen
am Morgen nicht erschrecken mit diesen
Gruselkabinett dass er sich dadurch
auszeichnet dass nur saskia ist wenn das
einzige Frau beteiligt ist aber
unabhängig davon wir haben noch 12 Tage
bis zur Wahl ich bin auch eine
Bundestagsvizepräsident auch wenn ich
daran arbeite dass die fdp-stärkste
Fraktion wird und wieder die
Bundestagspräsidenten stellen aber die
haben zwölf Tage bis zur Wahl wir
kämpfen jetzt alle darum der
fdp-vorsitzender und
vize-stellvertretender
Bundestagspräsident ich wollte sie nicht
zu mehr machen als sie ohnehin schon
sind der Kubicki keine Sorge herzlichen
Dank wie gesagt wir kämpfen jetzt alle
um möglichst große mehr ich kann nur
wieder sagen die stärker die Freien
Demokraten werden desto größer ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit einer vernünftigen
einer pragmatischen Politik die
tatsächlich unser Land aus dem
Dämmerschlaf herausholt und wieder nach
vorne bringt alles weitere werden wir
nach der Wahl sehen ich habe das schon
immer wieder erklärt ich gehe nach wie
vor davon aus dass eine Chance besteht
dass Armin Laschet eine
Jamaika-Koalition zustande bringt
selbstverständlich werden wir als Freie
Demokraten auch eine Einladung von Olaf
Scholz verfolgen was denn sonst wir sind
ja demokratische Parteien aber nach wie
vor gilt es gibt doch sehr hohe Hürden
für eine abwehrkoalition die zu
überwinden wir momentan schwer fällt
daran zu glauben ich kann mir schwer
vorstellen dass Sozialdemokraten und
Grüne auf ihre steuererhöhungspläne
verzichten wollen ich kann definitiv
ausschließen für die Freie Demokraten
dass wir uns an einer Rewe beteiligen
die in ihrem Programm Steuererhöhung hat
lassen Sie uns mal noch mal auf das auf
keinen fallkabinett das sagen sie eben
gerade Gruselkabinetts genannt der
Kubicki was finden sie da denn welche
Positionen finden Sie da denn besonders
schlimm
ja eigentlich alle also Heiko Maas hat
sich als völlig untauglich erwiesen für
jedes Regierungsamt Saskia esken macht
schon durch ihre Ausstrahlung deutlich
dass es kein Zukunft sein könnten Kevin
Kühnert hat ja mit 29:30 Uhr Semestern
bewiesen dass er bisher kein Studium
absolviert hat das qualifizieren nicht
unbedingt zumindest da Rolf
mützenrichtlinie sehr der wäre nach
meiner Auffassung tatsächlich auch
regierungs-tauglich Karl Lauterbach Gott
bewahre uns da vor dieser
Gesundheitsminister wird das wäre die
Verschlimmerung einer Fortsetzung der
Politik von Jens Spahn also nach wie vor
das entscheidet im Zweifel auf die
soziale Demokratie zum Schluss allein
aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
wir von ihr genannten Personen viel in
einem Kabinett Scholz wiederfinden
würden ich glaube Olaf Scholz hätte auch
wie ich vor diesem vor dieser kam jetzt
Besetzung wirklich Angst wir haben
gestern ein bisschen bzw heute ein
bisschen bedauert hier und wollen Ihnen
kein Honig um den Bart schmieren aber
das wäre Christian Lindner beim
materiell nicht dabei war das hätte
passieren können wenn er sich selber
auch zum oder die Partei ihn zum
Kanzlerkandidaten erklärt hätten sowie
Grün das ja auch gemacht dann kann ja
jeder machen guido Westerwelle hat es
auch schon gemacht 2002 warum haben sie
sich nicht getraut
ja weil klar war dass wir die nächsten
Kanzler nicht stellen werden wegen der
Größenordnung das war übrigens auch für
die Grünen klar ich weiß jetzt ist es
klar sonst könnte der SSW ja auch
teilnehmen wenn er seinen Abgeordneten
der kandidierten Kanzlerkandidaten
ausruft warum ich verstehe auch nicht
warum die Sender nicht darauf reagieren
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass an in
der bareburg Kanzlerin wird gegen Null
tendiert deshalb hat sie eigentlich in
einem solchen trial oder Duell nichts
mehr zu suchen wenn man sollte darauf
reagieren dass die Chancen für Armin
Laschet und Olaf Scholz in etwa gleich
verteilt sind nach wie vor die beiden
sollten miteinander ringen um die Frage
wer führt das Land aber nicht der
anderen in der Werbung und wir schon gar
nicht wie gesagt wir wollen nicht kannst
da nicht stellen obwohl Christian
Lindner wie ich finde ein besserer
Kanzler wäre als die drei Kandidaten die
momentan da sind
Herr Kubicki Armin Laschet will jetzt
aufholen er will jetzt die Trendwende
schaffen nun höre ich aus ihrer Partei
das durchaus die Sorge besteht dass er
das vielleicht wenn er das schafft ist
auf ihre Kosten schafft haben sie Angst
wenn Sie wünschen Armin Laschet ja ein
Wahlsieg sie wollen ja eine
schwarz-gelbe Koalition aber haben sie
Angst dass die FDP dann vielleicht
runterladen könnte
nein diese Angst habe ich nicht die
Union muss schon für sich selbst sorgen
die Wählerinnen und Wähler die uns
momentan unterstützen wollen die Freien
Demokraten wollen eine vernünftige
Politik am liebsten in einer
jamaika-konstellation die wir immer noch
versuchen herzustellen wenn nicht wollen
unsere wieder jedenfalls dass die
Politik der Deutschlands künftig
vernünftig sein wird also noch einmal
ich habe keine Angst vor den erworzen
oder den Erklärungen der Union gestern
zu Recht gesagt wir haben vernünftige
Politik will muss jetzt nicht mehr auf
die Union setzen kann auf die Freien
Demokraten setzen ich bin sicher wir
werden noch zum Beitrag zulegen und die
Union tätigen gut daran sich darum zu
kümmern dass sie auch stärker wird denn
nur sonst nur so schaffen wir einen
jamaika-konstellation ansonsten werden
wir sehen was die Wiener Wähler am
Beitrag entscheiden aber auch rot grün
Herr Kubik haben wir hier diskutiert
kann man das Mitte Linksbündnis nennen
so wie es jetzt in den
öffentlich-rechtlichen gefallen ist
ja das ist
nummerklatur also man kann sagen was man
will ich glaube nicht dass Rot Grün Rot
eine eine Mitte Linksregierung wäre es
wäre Linksverschiebung innerhalb
Deutschlands es wäre eine linke
Koalition und keine Mitte links
Koalition aber noch einmal diese
geografischen
Einschätzungen sind ich das was die
Menschen wirklich interessiert sie
wollen wissen können sie ihren Wohlstand
erhalten behalten sie ihre Arbeitsplätze
werden wir mit technologischen
Animationen im Klimawandel fertig können
wir uns wirklich mal um die Schulen und
reden nicht nur drüber das sind die
Themen die Konstellationen wer mit wem
das ergibt sich nach der Wahl wir
wollten uns hier nicht gegenseitig ins
Wort fallen so wie im Triel sorry noch
mal ein Patricia
mal realistisch betrachtet was glauben
sie können Sie wirklich dann von ihren
Forderungen am Ende egal die Grünen
werden auf jeden Fall in einer neuen
Regierung davon muss man ausgehen dabei
sein wenn sie auch dabei sind was werden
sie tatsächlich aufgeben müssen
das Spannende ist ja dass man
Verhandlungen nicht beginnt mit der
Frage was gibt man auch sondern mit der
Frage was setzt man durch es gibt rote
Linien für uns das wissen alle
Beteiligten die rote Linie ist keine
Steuererhöhung die rote Linie ist kein
Aufweichen der Schuldenbremse und eine
weitere rote Linie ist eine wirklich
schnelle Rückkehr zur grundrechtlichen
Normalität in der Pandemie und darüber
hinaus dass dänischen Modell ist etwas
was ich persönlich sehr stark
favorisiere aber noch einmal in dem
wahrscheinlichsten Konstellationen
Jamaika oder Ampel werden jedenfalls
grüne und Freie Demokraten Freie
Demokraten und Grüne vertreten sein ich
kann nur sagen ich habe 2017 bei
Verhandlungen mit den Grünen in
Schleswig-Holstein mit Robert Habeck
wirklich keine schlechten sondern gute
Erfahrungen gemacht weil wir alle
respektiert haben dass wir vom anderen
nichts erwarten letztendlich leisten
kann das ist eine Basis für Gespräch und
für Verständigung wie gesagt alles
weitere sieht man am Ende eines solchen
Tages und nicht am Anfang
sie haben aber jetzt klare rote Linien
aufgezeigt und eine dieser roten Linien
ist die corona-politik die Rückkehr zur
Normalität und jetzt stellen wir uns
doch mal vor das Karl Lauterbach der mit
Abstand bekannteste Gesundheitspolitiker
der Republik und auch der SPD nun doch
Gesundheitsminister wird können Sie sich
das vorstellen oder ist Karl Lauterbach
für Sie auch eine rote Linie
ich kann Lauterbach ist keine rote Linie
und er ist auch den deutschen insgesamt
schwer zu übermitteln noch einmal wir
werden ja wenn wir
Koalitionsverhandlungen führen zunächst
uns über Inhalte unterhalten was ist die
Grundlage einer
regierungsmöglichkeit der nächsten vier
Jahre dann wird man sich über die Frage
unterhalten wer wird welches ressoure
setzen und damit man sich anschließend
über die Frage unterhalten darf man als
Partei mitreden bei der Frage wie andere
Parteien ihre Ressourcen Zweifel
besetzen noch einmal ich glaube nicht
dass Karl Lauterbach auf dem Zettel von
Olaf Scholz ist und der Rest ist wie
gesagt
[Musik]